I don't mind
my name is Emre I had thought I thought
of a time machine that basically ran on
all the data based on your brain so it
basically calculated all the information
on your brain and all the data in your
life that would and it would create a
vortex which you would go back through
and you would go back in time so it's a
time machine
now I was thinking that if you went back
once you would have the memory of going
back so that would create another vortex
in which you would go through again and
and once you got to the dimension work
which was in the past the other time
machines with your memory would because
you're the person you it would also form
another vortex which would go through
and you keep going through infinite
vortexes until your husband come in
infinite space and time now I would my
question is would it be possible to
generate enough electricity to be able
to create another vortex which would
accelerate time and bring you and
generate enough power to bring you back
um that all the way back to your time
and and keep it stable with all the with
the old time machine and you in it so
could you please answer that well of
course it's very straightforward
question what so one of the whole
problems
MRA is that right memory one of the old
problems in all science fiction stories
that involve time travel is can you go
back in time and change things so that
you didn't exist can you but go back in
time and change things so that by the
time it's now you're fabulously wealthy
can you go back in time and change
so that the world is completely
different and better or can you go back
in time and accidentally screw
everything up these are old questions in
science fiction and I got to say so far
know however you can't however recently
by recently last 10 years some
physicists and ablai I remember this
these guys were in Japan showed that you
could build a time machine if you are
allowed to travel near the speed of
light in this time machine in a big
circle and you could only go back in
time to when the machine was built this
is in theoretical physics however in
order to go faster or as close to the
speed of light you need enormous amounts
of energy and it might stretch you where
your head is going being accelerated
more than your feet and it would kill
you maybe these are great questions and
I noticed you use the word vortex a lot
a vortex is a whirlpool like a the
center of a hurricane is a vortex and
when the water goes down the drain and
the bathtub
that's a vortex and there's a fabulous
thing i hope you learn about in a whole
discipline called fluid mechanics the
mechanisms by which fluid flows called
vorticity vorticity zuv fabulous word so
I appreciate you throwing around the
word vortex but I'm not sure it's
exactly what you mean when you talk my
time travel but think about it can you
go back in time and change things so
that you never existed so it's an old
question in science fiction and it's
cool but as far as anybody knows time
only goes one way and as far as anybody
knows nobody knows why that is going
back in time is really hard and it's
related to this thing that has to do
with heat heat always spreads out
heat never spontaneously concentrates on
its own by spontaneous I mean on its own
without influence and the example I'll
give you go all over the world look at
everything you're ever going to look at
look at a glass of water look at a lake
look at a pond they never just freeze in
the summertime it never happens the heat
doesn't go down to the bottom of the
pond or up into the atmosphere and the
apartment freezes on its own energy
always spreads out and when you ever eat
something spreads out it's doing it's
moving over a distance over time so time
and the spreading out of energy are
intimately connected or closely related
and there's something about that that
keeps us from building time machines
carry on